The joe rogan experience.
Joey.
Oh,
Joey Diaz calm.
Yeah,
but damn,
you got 18 say bitch ass shit ain't
going to work in here.
Hung Up.
T and t doesn't work in here.
Yeah,
but a column call it called Joe Joey
really quick.
I think he knows I'm on the podcast.
He probably wants to say something.
It's probably hard as fuck right now.
Joe Rogan.
What is he going to say?
Predict,
uh,
what he would say Eddie Bravo.
I told you I told you.
Cock saga.
Electric Chair all day.
Let's see.
You have reached the voice.
Oh yeah.
Something might have happened.
It might've got pulled into a meeting
and Joey Diaz,
his Bolo on the fuck up.
He's selling out everywhere.
He's constantly getting brought in from
meetings and fucking people want them to
do movies and it's just,
it's incredible.
It's incredible scene.
Okay.
Yeah,
he's okay.
I might've went over the four oh five or
something.
This is it.
I have to ask you this.
Okay.
Did the,
did the Indian come out after
party?
No.
I don't feel it.
I don't know.
It was like,
no,
probably so tired right now.
I just didn't feel it,
Joey.
Oh,
it's ringing.
Check this out.
I think it's going to work.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not sure if he's going to answer.
How are you?
Good to be a gangster.
You're on the radio.
Tell him,
tell him you love that you're live on
the podcast.
I'm telling you right now dog.
Damn.
It feels good to be a beautiful,
ah,
you got out.
He was full on a child's flags at half
mast.
Okay.
It's over.
That's all I love to say.
I love you.
Hello.
Do you mind?
We love you too,
man.
Thank you.
He came in and just dropped a bomb right
there.
He's the greatest.
Joey Diaz.
The greatest.
What we need is a food emancipation
proclamation.
We need a food emancipation proclamation
to free the food system from the
enslavement of bureaucratic orthodoxy
so that consenting adults,
and I'm choosing my words very carefully
here so that consenting adults could
make a voluntary choice of food choice,
the type that they want from the source
that they want.
And if we allowed however many in our
society,
5% 10% 20% whoever didn't come,
whoever wanted to opt out of government
sanctioned orthodoxy and say,
hmm,
is there something better out here?
Can I choose something different?
If anybody who wanted to opt out of the
of the current industrial government
orthodoxy could do so,
voluntary consenting adults here,
you know we're talking about the right
of private contract.
If I want to,
if I want to come to your farm
voluntarily,
no extortion here,
okay,
voluntarily look around,
smell around,
ask around and I want what you're
producing.
I should be able to get it.
When the government gets between my lips
and my throat,
I call that an invasion of privacy.
And yes,
I do also believe that we should
legalize all drugs,
all of them.
Because the government that can tell you
you can't smoke dope can also tell you
you can't drink raw milk or,
or,
or refuse to vaccinate your children or
you know,
go down the line.
The fact is that the orthodoxy is so
convoluted now that it's perfectly safe
and fine to feed your kids.
Coca Cola,
mountain dew count Chocula cheerios and
pop tarts,
but not homemade charcuterie,
pickles,
raw milk and backyard butcher chickens.
Not Crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
And if we would free up,
I mean I travel a lot.
I talked to thousands and thousands of
farmers.
I just talked to 200 farmers up in San
Jose this weekend.
You know,
and what's the limiting factor?
Why is local food cheap?
Why is our kind of food,
I mean cheap,
more expensive,
uh,
that it has to be.
Why are we perceived as elitist?
Why isn't it more available?
Why is it so hard to find integrity
food?
This is the issue.
And if we would free up those of us in
the system that are ready to access our
neighbors with quiche and noodles and
charcuterie and you know a name,
your name,
it to free us up,
it would,
it would completely invert the entire
food system in a year.
That's what's weird about like bill
o'reilly or the Big Bang theory or any
of those shows,
is they have this perfect opportunity at
any moment to blow people's minds by
just making 180 degree turn just turning
in some complete opposite direction.
Imagine if bill had me direct an episode
of Big Bang theory with no notes.
Yes,
there's going to be a lot of active,
but you'd have to write it to you
couldn't know I can I,
if I,
if I have creative liberties with the
script,
yes,
I can get as many gay teens is.
I want God,
that'd be so fun.
That'd be so fun.
If like they had to do that at once a
year.
They had to let underground artists edit
and direct their shows just to see what
it would turn into.
Why that would be a terrible idea.
Be Fun.
Yeah,
it'd be fun for you,
but just low stakes shows,
sitcoms,
you know it's not low stakes because
imagine if it was your show and then
some fucking dj doug pound comes along
and he's like,
I'd like to direct your show for a week
and be like,
fuck you man.
We're going to kill your whole cast.
No,
you're not man.
No.
Who wants to watch that shit?
Listen man,
trust me.
Seven 18 it's going to be awesome.
They wake up and it's all a dream
though.
That's the,
that's the caveat.
Blossom becomes a demon.
They all start eating babies.
Baby Salad every day,
but we'll just use like rubber baby
dolls.
Don't worry.
But if bill o'reilly came out for one
show in drag
and just it's like this is who I am now.
It doesn't really explain it.
Same Guy and he's the same guy.
It's just like,
this is who I am.
This is how I've changed deal with it.
That would be as big as Geeth.
I'd be as big as Jesus.
That is how Jesus will come back.
It will be below right now.
Wilamena we'll Amena o'reilly and he
starts slowly beginning of a
transformation to the female gender.
Yeah.
That would be incredibly,
it just tells you like the reason why he
was like that.
It's just she was scared,
scared all the time that people find out
that he identifies with being a woman
and that's where all the hate came from,
the homophobia,
all the Jesus' love,
all that craziness that was,
he was into.
It was really just,
I wanted to be a woman and then he just
starts putting pictures of his news,
surgical crusty below or ile pussy up on
it and people just,
it causes waves of suicide.
But here's what's crazy.
People still spot him out at night,
like dress like a man and he looks
perfectly normal and they realize it's
just a fucking scam.
Like everything else he does.
He's not really becoming a woman.
It's just a bullshit artist.
That would be one of the salvage.
No,
it's what happens is you realize
someone's blackmailing him.
You realize somebody has something worse
than that and they're like,
listen,
bill,
that's like a house of cards move.
Here's what I want you to do on your
show.
What do you think?
Oh my God.
You know,
I've got these pictures of you fisting
chimpanzees,
chimps,
water.
I was doing it for Jesus.
So it goes in and tide goes out.
You don't know why it fits chimps
who could explain it?
God moves in mysterious ways while their
fist and I to wear a dress.
You fucking Cock sucker.
I'm not wanting to go out.
That's my deal,
my personal life.
Eh?